bismillah hamdulillah assalamualaikum
greetings a piece I want to cover three
important points with you and I want you
guys to imagine during this pandemic
plan Demick whatever you want to call it
but ultimately it's all in the plans and
the hands of Allah the Creator that
happens on earth the fear that people
are feeling the mainstream media
constantly in your face death and gloom
and doom and how people are really
scared now I want you to think for a
moment that that's same fear that they
are having now for the new terrorists on
a block how when the media starts to
push this misinformation lies
half-truths about Islam and Muslims how
the people feel it's that same fear many
people when they're constantly bombarded
with all the misinformation how do they
feel - what's the solution education my
brothers and sisters we have been called
upon by the creator that has an earth to
be ambassadors to this Deen although
Allah sabili Rebecca bill hikmah - well
mo Allah tell Hassan at iwo jared el
humility here asan invite invite - who
invite to the way of your Creator - God
Almighty Allah with hikmah with wisdom
with beautiful preaching invite them and
now what's one of the best ways along
with having noble character along with
being of good manners along with being
honest dignified but also when someone
needs direction and - how to get from
point A to B you got a share if you know
that information and we have to share
the information of what the truth is
about this Deen about Islam submission
to create or not the creation we have to
share it but how do we share it now
number three is through media through
what we've been doing since
alhamdulillah
2006 we've been sharing we've taken on
the task at hand Allah to help clear the
misconceptions about Islam
bringing out scholars bringing out
guests people from all
all walks of life sharing their stories
this has had an amazing effect on so
many people and alhamdulillah we are
continuing the work but we need your
support and every year we do our global
campaign and this is it this year we're
trying to reach our goal and we need
your help
if you benefit from the program if you
have been one who has supported us over
the years thank you very much for those
new to the Deen show o to the D show
whoever you are
do your part help contribute help us
reach our goal
share this keep us in your duas and if
we can accomplish these things if we can
understand that the key to that fear
Radek a ting it is education and that
education if you care you share that's
through the Dawa and that's our part of
fulfilling our duties to our Creator and
to helping make humanity a better place
because this Deen has solutions to all
the problems and to reach more of a
global audience we need the media and
that's what we are when the first
Islamic TV talk shows in America one of
the few one of the only here and we need
your support support do it now and
continue to tune in here to the Deen
show we'll see you next time every week
same time same channel until then peace
be with you
assalamualaikum